personally i was looking for something
to protect me while i was on my travels
put it inside yeah we can prepare like
the amulet okay and the person put it in
the pocket
in the back something with you
he was in africa and he saw them
doing witchcraft tying the knots we call
that those amulets here
actually yes what they use they use
amulets uh we see beautiful nature and
you know lions and whatnot did you ever
get to you know walk around and see a
lion walking walking around somewhere
can a man
become a woman
this is your brother imam musa azam i
would like to encourage all of our
muslim community consider giving
generously for this noble cause that is
desperately in need and need of overtime
mega dhawa center is needed to address
the islamophobia effectively and this is
what brother eddie trudean show has been
doing whose reach is now just as it with
the dean's show over five million
imagine if we give eddie the dean center
how much more we will be able to reach
and how many people are going to benefit
from it once allah accepted any effort
from your side then he gives you another
project and that is a sign of acceptance
of the previous work brother eddie have
started his dean show allah grant
acceptance to it now he gave him another
opportunity to have the dean center to
serve the humanity it is our duty my
beloved to do whatever we can to support
and bring this into reality desperately
needed funds and with it with that we'll
be able to bring this into existence 35
000 square foot building will come into
existence as a mega dawah center here in
america that will serve millions for
generations to come so my below please
do not miss out this opportunity to take
part in this noble cause a historical
thing that's about to take place please
donate generously as soon as possible
[Music]
bismuth greetings of peace now my next
guest dr sreeno omar berry is the vice
chancellor president of the islamic
international open university has served
as permanent secretary minister of
higher education research science and
technology minister of health and social
welfare minister of youth and sports
minister of defense and at the office of
the president of gambia and the list
goes on
now he was born in a muslim family in
sub-saharan africa where there were and
still are many unislamic ideologies and
practices that he was exposed to now how
did he navigate through all of them and
get to the position to where he is today
as the vice president of the iou now
this is a very important episode because
you might be confused trying to identify
what is islam from all of these islamic
practices and from all the weird things
that you might have seen that some
people associate with islam that
actually have nothing to do with islam
so let's bring them on out
how are you
[Music]
dr omar berry
i'm very fine i'm okay and thank you
very much i'm also selling my greetings
to all those who are listening and
watching
so you
had quite an experience growing was this
growing up in sub-saharan africa
yes um well let me say that sub-saharan
africa has really
been a hub of islamic evolution in many
many ways
and wait wait wait wait
before we get to all that because we
think africa and we think you know
we see beautiful nature and you know
lions and whatnot did you ever get to
you know walk around and see a lion
walking walking around somewhere
well i might be much luckier than you
i'm not seeing a lion per se you know in
the nature itself but i've seen it in
the zoo but let me see also that i have
seen a lot of other animals in the
nature uh ones that you might not often
find in very developed countries today
um they will find find most of them cave
but yeah i mean africa has also gone a
long way in that evolution now you don't
find most
most of the wild animals very easily
yeah but you can you can take don't do
they have trips they're like tour guides
that you go you could jump in a jeep and
go to certain areas there and you can
actually be close to them we see a lot
of video footage you know yes in our
part of africa it's difficult to find
the kind of animals that you might
probably want to see but if you go to
the eastern part of africa in kenya for
more precisely in tanzania and other
places they have got very huge nature
reserves so therefore they've still got
the wild animals in their own natural
habitats and you can find them in congo
for example you can find the chimpanzees
in kenya you can find still the zebras
and the lions but in our part of africa
now the development and a lot of
agricultural
activities have really thrown um said
made animals run away so we hardly find
them easily now i mean we ourselves we
also have to see them cage to be able to
appreciate them yeah so go ahead what
were you saying
uh yes i was saying that yeah we we live
in uh in the subterrane okay let's more
precisely in west africa we've got um a
very
interesting evolution of islam
and most of us who are born we are born
inside that deen you know inside we are
born as muslims as we call it and
therefore we grow up you know practicing
the you know the islam that we have
on the ground and with time we've had
the opportunity now with the exposure of
knowledge through all media
schools sprouting islamic schools and
all we are now conscious of a lot of
other things that we might have probably
neglected or might have not been taken
into serious consideration in our
practice of the gene and therefore it
has brought some new
uh emerging thoughts and emerging
practices or let's say it has brought
some kind of um
a a revival of some of the things that
we might have lost but have been lost
with time uh which have probably been
influenced by our cultural practices uh
you know because of the way we live and
islam has not naturally easily i mean
not condemn most of it at the beginning
and therefore it has kind of influenced
the way we practice until at some point
we might have forgotten some of the
basis uh basics so
uh today we have we are seeing some
emergence of a lot of these things and
therefore we will see
probably in the course of this
discussion what are those and how it has
influenced the
new thoughts particularly among the
youths like us
so are you considered like a real
african
oh yes yes i'm culturally real african
from generation many many generations
back and i'm from a family that is very
much attracted to islam also in in
almost eight or nine generations up you
know so yes
how how big is how prominent is islam
what percentage of africa is actually
muslim
oh okay maybe africa would be too large
for me to say because i'm not check the
statistics but let me look at west
africa west africa is very very
islamized you know we have senegal
mauritania
uh mali gambia burkina faso kinako
nakari so we have a light population of
muslims in these countries if you go to
certain other countries nigeria for
example is divided into the north and
the south and you find that in the south
they are more christianized because when
when the colonialism colonial
colonialists came and wanted really to
convert their states you know into
christians to be able to better rule
them so they can read and write and
understand what they are saying so they
succeeded in nigeria by dividing the
place into two because they already had
the north that was very well islamized
as a result of the
of the works of assassination
who converted most of the house into
islam and therefore it was difficult to
convert them to christianity but those
in the south who were anemists were
easily converted and therefore you have
this kind of two religions
side by side in fact if you look at
their political system they always
encourage a president who is a muslim
having a vice president who is a
christian or a president who is a
christian having a vice president who is
a muslim just to be able to make sure
that the body north and the south do not
go in conflict even at that level but
then in most of other countries like
gina kanakri in senegal gambia as i
mentioned
you find that the percentage of muslims
are almost at 90 percent
so the number of christians are very
very minimal even though there is this
tolerance and cohabitation that that
doesn't create any tension between the
two religions
tell me we you navigating through all of
this
things that have nothing to do with
islam you talk about in your early years
one thing that comes to my mind is a
previous guest that i had on the program
brother john and he talked about he was
studying islam and he
read the surah al-falaq mass these
towards the end of the quran the
vibrating word of god almighty and then
he was in africa and he saw them
doing witchcraft tying the knots
right so
is this really prevalent there that they
have this witchcraft and they have
people dealing with the gin and stuff
like this
okay um maybe to to clarify that further
we call that those amulets here
actually yes what they use they use
amulets that's right yeah they use the
name of god and then they write it in
kind of a very string um boxes you know
you have this you know in europe you
have this kind of a box where you have
the the
nine nine squares in which you have five
in the middle and say if you add it
diagonally you get the same amount you
add it horizontally and vertically you
know that kind of
string kind of numerical so they believe
some of them have really uh studied this
kind of mystic ways of translating the
name of god into that kind of into this
kind of letters so what they do is they
create a whole
you know in an a4 paper for example they
write
very string figures on them and then
they will now tie this up into a kind of
a skin
you know and even the skin the skin of a
goat for example that has been dried and
then scraped until all the hair is off
and then they will tie it in that kind
of a skin and then they will have it now
properly sewn also with skin not with
thread and then once it is done then
they will put a hole across it and then
they will tie some a band around it it
could either be put around your waist or
around your arm
or around your neck or even on your head
sometimes if some people want to expose
it and they would make you believe it
has some magical elements in it it can
for example protect you from a bullet
getting through your body you if
somebody shoots at you it will not get
in uh some people will make you believe
that if you wear it you can even
disappear you will not be seen by mortal
eyes so yes we have had this and i
ironically they use the quran they use
the scripture to use that to be able to
write these kinds of strange stuff and a
lot of people do believe it and by the
way islam considers this a silk
because it is a way of believing
something being more powerful in
protecting you more powerful in in in
saving you or whatever and therefore you
equate it with god and in some points
you even take that to be the sole
possible source of your protection
forgetting that you know your creator is
actually the main source and it has led
a lot of people in you know in serious
conditions of
getting out of the gene because you know
silk is one of the highest
you know uh since in in islam so once
you are into that and while we're tiny
amulets around your waist and your and
your arms and everywhere even sometimes
across your chest and everything so
basically you you feel that without
those you are not normal part of you
know i mean you're not protected you're
not safe so you forget completely that
there are other ways of protecting
yourself that has been established by
islam through our prophet muhammad saw
but you did not you will not study those
because you believe and trust that this
amulets will save you now others also
have a way of giving you these kinds of
things and they ask you to soak it in
water to give it to your husband so that
he will love you more to give it to an
enemy so that the person will go mad or
crazy or put it in their food or in
their drinks so we have been having this
going on and you know the strange thing
is that these beliefs sometimes turn out
to come true i mean it's you know evil
has a way of coming
becoming real in in our lives the more
you believe it the more it can turn real
so some people really go mad when
they're giving this these concoctions or
some people
you know go barren or others are really
affected so as a result people believe
that it works
because that's the way satan works you
know it makes them believe that it
actually works so yeah it is something
very prevalent
in our a part of the world and it has
been
uh unfortunately so mixed up with our
religion that some people still believe
that it is all part of our religion
so how did you coming up as a young man
and then getting to where you are today
how i mean navigate through all of the
different sects that are out there and
some of these things that you had
mentioned to come to the position where
you're at someone now who's living by
the quran and the sunnah
but you have to go through a journey and
being exposed to all this so other
people can relate when they see certain
weird things and they think like oh my
god what
does this have to do with islam doesn't
it and people mix it together with islam
so there's the confusion how did you get
through this and navigate through all of
this
thank you very much i think the whole
thing unfortunately is that we neglect a
lot
discovering our religion or finding out
more about our religion and that's what
has been our problem most of us because
we've been comfortably born in
an islamic society we tend to follow
leaders
um most of whom unfortunately also
haven't got probably adequate knowledge
of the deed itself and their own
practice is not the correct practice of
the game
and unfortunately then we really go
astray so so uh yeah we growing up young
we have also been wearing amoled you
know we have been
we've gone through the whole the whole
practice that i've just described and at
the time nobody would have made me
believe that it's not true in fact i
would fight with anyone who tells me
that what i'm what i'm doing it's not
islamic it's an islamic you yourself you
you you you yourself were so convinced
of it at one point that you were you
would fight somebody who told you
otherwise huh
oh yes yes yes i mean most of i mean i
have a lot of people who will who will
associate to that especially from this
part of africa you know what they will
make you believe is that you wear this
amulet around your waist you know you
have a way of protecting yourself
against bad guys you know and you
believe it and then you you you are
giving this and you pay a huge amount of
money to a marabou they will call them
here these these guys who prepare these
things and they ask you to wear them and
they will probably have to even
sacrifice alarm and things like that and
sometimes maybe even the blood or
something would all be mixed up in the
kind of a ritual to make sure that you
are all protected and everything so
naturally you believe it and then you
you tie this around your waist they tell
you when you're going to the toilet you
don't put it take it in the toilet
because it has the name of god and all
these things so they have they have the
whole story around so you keep wearing
it and you keep protecting yourself um
believing it is protecting you
and naturally you will not do what this
requires you to do to protect yourself
and then you know so because you don't
know because you have not studied it so
what happened really is that most of us
decided therefore to embrace education
you know and this is what the
international open university has always
been about is to make sure that people
discover their own deed through the
through through the books you know i
have to read
it's not only meant for a prophet
muhammad
actually it is meant for mankind the the
fact that you must read means that you
must discover your deen throughout the
course of your life so the more you
discover the more you realize that there
are many many ways you can live a much
simpler life without having to depend on
all these gadgets around your body can
you imagine if i were to go to the
airport and i have about three of them
tied around my waist you know in an
airport security check and i have five
of them around my waist and some of them
around my neck i mean they will probably
take me straight to the psychiatric unit
believing that i might be going crazy
but people believe it and
i have we have seen this happening until
today and we've been trying our best
also to educate other people to inform
them that through the knowledge that
they will gain by reading the quran by
reading
the sunnah what the sunnah requires for
your protection what the sun requires
for your association with other people
gradually people are trying to shun it
away and throwing it away and today i'm
i'm really free you don't you don't i
mean when i go to
when i practice my deen i know what i
can read you know during salad after
salad i know what i should do in zikr
protect myself when i'm going to bed i'm
getting to in a place uh talking to a
crowd etc so and these things are the
practices of the prophet muhammad we do
not know them we do not practice them at
all dr sharina i want to get your
reaction now
to something
that here in america is a
topic that is
becoming more talked about
and
the person who made this documentary
it reminded me of you of showing you
this because this was actually in
in africa maybe you can identify where
in africa if you know this tribe i don't
think they're muslim but
hear what they have to say and get your
reaction to this and is this a is this a
topic that is discussed over in your
area as it is by us your thoughts on it
what if a man decides that his his
gender
identity is woman
a woman has its own duty and a man has
his own duty and a lady cannot duty the
duty of a man and a man cannot do a duty
of a woman
can a man
become a woman
no no it will look like to if you want
to become a lady but your man
you have something wrong
something wrong in your family something
wrong in you
what about if someone was non-binary
non-binary
do you know
like non
like someone is you're not a woman
you're not a man
yeah someone's like someone is neither
they're something else is that
a kid
he's saying we have never seen things
like those for a man he has a penis for
a woman he has a vagina so we know this
is a lady this is a man what if it's a
woman with a
what if it's a woman with a penis
[Laughter]
did you understand the language they
were speaking
actually i do not but i know they are
the messiah from kenya
i've been to kenya myself so i know them
to be the messiah these are basically
people who live in isolation in the in
the wilderness they mostly take care of
cattle
uh
mostly cattle and uh
in fact these masai are much shorter
than the normal massage they can be
taller than this so they live between
the swazi
where we call eswatini
uh your thoughts to what the
conversation was about are they having
this kind of conversation in africa like
they are having over here
trying to distinguish a man who's a
woman
it's a very it's a conversation that is
not very easily openly discussed you
know because people
uh don't feel that that kind of a
question i mean that kind of an issue is
really a big subject to discuss for two
reasons probably on one it is
disconforting to talk about people's
privacy you know they believe that when
you're talking about people
um private life or private sex
you know it's a kind of a privacy the
other thing is that it can be very
shocking when you bring up issues that
people are not used to hear
um and they are more used to seeing it
over the over the tv or in movies or
maybe had it spoken about in the west
um the issue of for example uh
uh
a man from you know transforming himself
into a woman wasn't giving a call within
the communities here
um it's uh we've seen
men who have been behaving very womanly
you know to make it to to just bluntly
say it very nicely
you know but they have always been seen
to be people with problems they have
never been seen to be homosexuals for
example
so they are seen in the society as
people who have some psychological
issues
and therefore they are treated as such
as people are not correct
um and then we've not
in fact in some cases like on in in
cultural dances some certain cultural
practices you have men wearing women's
clothes and women wearing men's clothes
but they do that
just a way of teasing the other sex it's
a way of mocking a mockery to the order
to the opposite sex
so it's not done
as a way of life it's done on a
particular event you know just to share
that say that the woman saying to the
man you see i can wear your clothes and
look like you and the man said yes i can
also wear your clothes and look like you
so it is more fun than than really aware
of life
so if you look at the questions they
have been asking it's
you know they have been if you look at
the guys to answer they're a little bit
uneasy it's not that they're laughing
because it looks stupid but yeah they
are not comfortable discussing these
topics openly
they might talk to speak about it
amongst themselves in privacy and all
that but openly like that especially
within the strangers is very very
difficult and it's the same around this
end too so so it's not a talk about
topic of only discussion
yeah so you can imagine uh adults
feeling feeling uncomfortable to talk
about this but now they're pushing on
this
they're pushing this in the school
system on three four-year-olds yes
that's that's what's going on so
uh this is opens us up in the last uh
uh few minutes that we have to talk more
about
why
education is so important and this is
where you're the vice president of the
institution iou so talk to us about the
importance because like we started
navigating through all the confusion
if you got the proper education it's
going to help you not to fall into
hopefully god willing these traps by
shaytan
yes indeed
i'm happy that you mention it because
myself as an education consultant in
fact i have had the opportunity to sweep
around some of the curricula that we
have been
subjected to you to
recommend in the schools
including the exposure that most of our
children have through the social media
through the new tvs you know because now
with television you have a lot of movies
and series that are coming out and it
kind of attracts a lot of you know i
mean
um
attention in some families and
unfortunately most of the families are
not well educated to know how to protect
their children from
ex you know that that exposure they have
with the tv they think it's normal for
them to keep watching anything they
watch it's normal for them to read
anything daily it's not about to have a
phone a smartphone and then go online
and then go through the social media
um with all the kind of platforms that
we have now
uh what they do don't know unfortunately
is that the exposure is also changing
the mindset it's also exposing them to
another culture that is alien to the
kind of culture we're talking about you
know i mean if somebody like me who has
not had let's say that strong religious
background but we are waiting on islamic
religious family and you are not
practicing islam as it's required from
childhood because
you know it's just because you're a
muslim you believe that you should pray
five times a day but you're not praying
five times a day when the occasion
arises you don't have any fear in you
because you don't know much about your
religion now if you're exposed to that
kind of thing then you can easily be
influenced naturally and then then you
find that kind of culture coming now
creeping into your into your society
eventually you know molding your society
into a different way
and that fear i think should be in every
parent it should be in every policy
maker in the area of education uh very
recently there has been a lot of
structural adjustments happening
in our countries unfortunately it's not
kind of
the international open university that i
heard for example we've been reaching
out across the whole continent what we
are doing in fact we have in fact
appealed to
donors to help support the children who
might probably not afford it and provide
what we call the education which is an
islamized form of education
it brings the the virtues of islam not
only teaches us the values that we need
to to nurture as muslims but it also
helps through the books that we have and
through the education that system that
we provide to even islamize some of
these subjects like if you are doing
biology now if you're doing chemistry if
you're in physics you can do chemistry
biology and physics but you don't have
to do it in the same curricula that is
being exposed to the west you can do it
from an islamic perspective and study it
knowing that what you are studying has
some relevance into your life both in in
the dunya probably hereafter it has a
relevance of ensuring that you have you
know a passion for science and a passion
for us and a question for anything but
knowing also what is the rulings of
islam in all that you study and also
bringing some other islamic knowledge
like islamic psychology brings you a
different concept or perception of what
psychology is all about instead of
having to arrive in psychology from the
western perspective because the western
perspective as you know just to give an
example understand psychology from the
mind from the mind while the islamic
perspective can understand psychology
from the soul because the soul is not
understood by the western concept of
psychology they don't see this soul they
only see the mind so it's a physical
palpable thing that they use to study
psychology while islam uses all the
islamic
requirements
you know in order for you to understand
islamic psychology so yes we have an
islamic perception of our education
system and we are trying to encourage
some of the governments to also embrace
that because if you have a large
community of muslims and what they are
doing now they just have a curriculum
that is being dropped from the
from the west and imposed on your people
and naturally then they will be exposed
to a lot of other practices that are
alien to your dream
and if you are not careful then it
becomes something normal for you to do
it's something normal for you to believe
and when you don't believe it they make
you believe that if you don't believe it
then you are not you are not cultured
you are not
you are not wise you cannot leave it in
that kind of society if they can easily
make you believe that homosexuality is a
right
naturally then if you are not strong in
your deen if you don't understand what
is the basis of your belief you believe
that homosexuality is right and
naturally you will carry it along as a
kind of a culture
um so yes there's a lot to do
unfortunately around this end so it's a
kind of a battle between
those who are providing our support for
our education system and therefore as
they call it
who are pulling these things they said
if you are the one who fits you will
make you dance to the music to the tune
right
so naturally if you if we do not review
our own education system ourselves if
you do not do a kind of a complete
overhaul of the type of education we
give for our children naturally what we
do is we give them the education that we
are forced to give them because of the
support we receive and then we expose
them therefore to the kind of cultures
that we know our religion do not accept
we know our cultures do not accept and
we know it's not aware of life and then
we will lose eventually uh in their own
so this is why international university
stands firm to ensure that the kind of
education we provide is the islamized
concept of our of learning and
hoping that people who come through our
system and then believe in what we do
will also come out as skillful people
who understand how life is across all
subjects but at the same time understand
it from the islamic perspective
so now
for people who are serious about their
deen they want to get well grounded in
deen they want tools to be able to
navigate through all of the confusion
and all of the things that are out there
you know that can take them away from
the dean
they are ready they have some questions
they can go and learn more at the
website also one question that might
come to mind is this accredited is the
iou accredited
yes yes the international open universe
is accredited by the national uh
accreditation and quality assurance
authority of the gambia
we also have accreditation in
malawi with the national council for
higher education in malawi
and we have also reached out to many
countries where most of our students
have graduated and have been having
difficulties in getting their
certificates recognized we've entered
into agreements through their
governments and institutions that are
now accepting our students you know in
malaysia indonesia and pakistan and
other places so yes the iou is is
reaching out everywhere we have in the
states
a lot of students i know it's not very
easy for example in the states to get
the accreditation that is required but
we have a lot of our students who have
had the opportunity to study with us and
most of them probably are doing it just
for the love of knowing more about their
dean but those who are doing some of our
professional programs have also
succeeded
in on very rare occasions also have
universities that accept them because
accreditation in the gambia means a lot
too because in gambia the accreditation
process is very stiff and it also
follows the same
norms and standards
and guidelines that are recommended
internationally so it is not new that if
you are creating the gambit and you
cannot have the access
in other places just that when you're a
private institution now there are a lot
more
legal uh that you have to go through
to be able to have the recognition all
over because we don't have we have
mostly we are virtual uh except for the
headquarters that we have in the gambia
and the few campuses that we have built
in in some areas of africa because we
are entirely virtual it is also one
challenge we have before before the
covet 19 many people would not believe
that online education is a possibility
they would think that there is
there are still a lot of gaps in
ensuring quality and standard in that
kind of education they have now been
proven wrong
you know covered has come to prove that
wrong that there is a way of ensuring
you can get a full uh course online and
yet still maintain the same standards
you know in body content knowledge and
the and the delivery method so we are
trying to encourage also other
governments we have reached out to
rwanda some universities have invited us
to support them in the online education
a lot of other universities are
interested to to test with us
i'm just from nigeria last week and
we've talked to the application body
there they're interested they have not
embraced a full online education yet
they are still on open and distance
learning and e-learning but we're going
to get there we're going to get there
and i'm hoping that very soon
a lot of other people who are probably
deprived of education deprived of
opportunities would have university
education without having to travel
distances and at a very affordable cost
so i myself if i remember correctly i'm
i
you have two
two avenues there and i benefited
tremendously from both so you have the
one where you can go get the
the diplomas that you go there and you
complete
certain
modules and certain
subjects and you have the modules the
pdf you have the videos and then you you
graduate from those you i've i've taken
many of those i've benefited myself
tremendously then you have the other one
you have the other one where you're
going for your ba i've also then you get
the credit hours get those i've also
taken many of those i was i was doing
that for for many years so
uh i've also myself alhamdulillah
benefited tremendously so if somebody's
ready to get started and get out of the
confusion and get serious with their
dean get well grounded in the dean tell
them where they can go
international open university if you if
you get to the website
i o is www.iou.edu.gm
you will find a lot of information on
that website about how you can join us
and i'm happy you mentioned that i'm
happy you mentioned it because we have
also what we call free diplomas now now
we probably because of the nature of the
free
course a lot of people probably will not
be committed but we have very a token
fee of ten dollars for example sometimes
or twenty dollars for you to do a course
for example on on fear you know to
understand some of the basis of your of
your dean
know as your bradley said the platforms
are very interactive you have a video
that would allow you
you can download it you can even have it
on your on your mobile phone you can be
driving from your home to your workplace
and you can you can look through it on
the phone while you're in the bus
instead of having to waste your time
watching across the window you'll be
having something to occupy yourself for
you that you reach your destination if
you are in the in the in the in the tram
or you know as they say in the us if
you're in the metro you know in the
underground train going to home you
might have to spend about half an hour
45 minutes why not use that also exactly
so you haven't downloaded this internet
internet is difficult so you can follow
our courses and they're very very
convenient and easily you know adaptable
to all the system you can even have it
as an audio so only because we have the
audio version also on on the platform um
and then you can download the course uh
if you wish to
module you know you don't have to
download the whole book you download
your module only it could be about four
or five pages that you can carry in your
pocket and anytime you want to make
reference to it you bring it out and do
reference to it and then you know read
it through and all that so so we are
very flexible uh the flexibility is
really there when it comes to learning
uh for those people particularly in the
developed countries is very very easy
and then we have the diploma we have the
certificate and the diploma and the the
bachelor programs and even the post-post
graduate programs are on now we have
already developed master's programs
in all the other areas islamic studies
arabic you know banking and finance
islamic banking and fine business
administration iit so we are bringing
all of them up now and the bachelor's
matters programs are just about
two years and flexible too um you you
you don't have to even pay the full year
if you want you can pay per semester
it's just an enrollment it's not even a
teacher you enroll yourself with a very
minimal fee if you're in the u.s for
example
with about 300 or 350 dollars now you
can have a full four month course
something you hardly find in any
university in a year you pay less than a
thousand dollars and you have a full
year program you know certificate
program and i have to tell you this and
i'm trying to say this we've done an
asset management done by an american
design institute
that all those who are studying online
because of the nature of the platform
because of the nature of the delivery
mode of delivery you have the the
advantage of retaining more of that
knowledge than if you were to go in the
conventional four brick and mortar four
corner classroom
because the four quarter classroom has a
lot of other you know what we call
distractions and basically when the
lecture happens that's the end of it but
for you the lecture is available
multiple times in a video format in an
audio format you can read and listen and
listen you can have your book follow the
lecture you can do your assignments you
review the lecture you go again and do
your assignment something you cannot get
from a lecturer a lecturer will give you
a medicinal course and you check your
notes you have your book and that's the
end of it um so yes so it means that the
retention
percentage is much higher when you do an
online course so the io is proud to say
that the platform we have built so far
has been proven to be of high quality
very interactive very uh and it's not
you don't even have to need a high i.t
knowledge of it just basic idea how to
link in i mean log into your program get
directly to your platform and then you
know you can get access to your program
at your courses and that's the end of it
and you know the advantage also is that
you you do every model
and after every model or every two
models you have the opportunity to do a
test and once you do that assignments if
you pass it you know you get the pass
mark let's say 50
or 60 then it opens up your second two
models and you do them so it allows you
also to force you to keep revising those
module models until you are sure you
understand them well before you can do
the assignment and once you do the
assignment or the online online test you
get the minimum mark then the other ones
will automatically unlock themselves and
then allow you know how to do the next
one so it has a very interesting method
that i'm sure anybody who practices once
or twice you find it very very easy just
have to manage yourself time management
is important in this case and also you
know make sure that you you spend more
time uh on your learning than wasting
your time on tvs
exactly so i owe you is it's an
institution really where you can even
study from there and studying in another
university some people have been doing
it in the gambia they registered with us
and registered with national university
and the excel we were surprised at the
excel you know they just had to manage
their time well and they were able to
study in both universities and came out
you know with flying corners
thank you very much for spending some
time with us here on the dean show
thank you my respected brother and thank
you so much for this great opportunity
and i hope that what we have said here
will be of benefit to our listeners and
those who are doing us too
inshallah may allah bless you
so much
and i want to thank you guys for tuning
in so if you want to get serious about
your dean this is a great
resource i've actually benefited
from myself the iou go ahead and get
started today because
there are many distractions as he said
you could be on the train you could be
on the plane you can be
working out you can put those headphones
on instead of listening to music a lot
of the other toxic stuff that's out
there you could be getting educated and
then you can go ahead and decipher
what's the dean and what's not the dean
just like he did so go ahead and get
started with the iou i really highly
recommend it
and continue to tune in to the dean show
and if you wanted to update with the
dean center we're halfway there
completing this project so you can go
ahead and get involved
and we'll see you next time until then
subscribe if you haven't already and
we'll see you here on the dean show
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum i cannot leave without giving
you a gift if you are not yet muslim and
you're tuning in to see what these
muslims are talking about and you'd like
a free copy of the quran go and visit
the deenshow.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about islam call us at 1-800-662
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you assalamu alaikum now the the
pastor chose you know rather than having
the church tore down totally
and they they actually you know um
wanted it to continue as a house of
worship so people have this opportunity
to go ahead and make this a reality
brothers and sisters we're halfway there
this is your brother eddie from the dean
show and alhamdulillah we are purchasing
a 35 000 square foot property to build
the dean center
a dawah center a masjid the first of its
kind in america we are halfway there
we have 700 000 left that must be
collected
in order to close on the property
get the tremendous rewards by donating
right now may god almighty allah reward
all of you
[Music]